[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
why do they do this because we dare them
to we dare our viewers to scan the show
and see how they find one tiny mistake
we're kind of jerks about it yeah yeah
well so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers not one winner no one's
caught us because we're perfect
okay well tonight a fan in Iran I can't
believe this is so cool that we have a
fan in Iran yeah named dad bah says he
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when I was talking recently
about German Chancellor Angela Merkel
hey Conan I'm here from Iran the other
day on the show defer to the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel twice I believe
German Chancellor Angela Merkel has been
named the most powerful woman in the
world in a related story jay-z has left
fiancee for Angela Merkel but her name
is Angela Merkel yep I think the guy
needed time buddy okay all right well I
think I think it's amazingly cool that
we have a fan in Iran and I love this
guy
mm-hmm for being so far away in such a
distant land and and supporting us and
liking what we do but he's wrong okay
he's dead wrong he says it's Angela and
it's not Angela right Hey but I'm sorry
dad you're just mistaken it is
pronounced Angela with a soft G it's
true she used to pronounce her name with
a hard G Angela but that all changed as
she herself declared in his speech
before the German parliament earlier
this year via via negative slant in
cilium Paragons not for me to bring on
the D Drive best not you know go pass
that's why they come sucks this
Antiochus in the Dhamma - like - which
was love
what you have in Jesus still a vice
Bertram can me on Twitter as the
Deutschland films million and a bathroom
Allah yeah Mr boffin the abacus effect
of 1.5 million missing I'm the writer
enjoyed some coefficient ago Oh - laughs
I'll heal Mouton
he wants to Jesus steel in my vehicle
once I buy my own a vehicle that has
decided taller side of a valley as
Englishmen were finished he mentioned
the Albert who kind of bookish
Albuquerque maja polish excellent life
on that steel Purina mention it again
[Applause]
no Ganesh son and via this industry I
know Osama but then it is off guard
absence Delia and thus Morgan danger
then there's el mine damage did mention
pseudonym than the physical disk an
artisanal deep
also Foxtrot idea mr. Bligh's
performance
[Music]
[Applause]
well ladies and gentlemen the challenge
still stands and it's a challenge I put
out to the entire world as you can now
see if you think you supported an era on
our show reported it team koco.com / ha
ha I found an error we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
little break when we come back jesse
eisenberg is here
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please